okay so Kirsten Cinema is out from
democratic party she's now an
independent and these kind of moral
decisions are things that I like chewing
on and thinking about so regardless of
your affiliation what part of your I'm
Canadian it doesn't even matter
on the one hand you know she was from
the green party she let the green party
become a Democrat and she's she got
elected she lost his green party she won
as a Democrat and she got elected to
serve her people as a Democrat right if
she was a green party if she was
independent she wouldn't she wouldn't
have won the election so she won being a
Democrat but on the other hand she feels
like she can't be part of the democratic
party anymore
and and doesn't want to be there
I see both sides like where is your
loyalty you know is it to the people who
elected you or is it to yourself and the
morals and and what you want to create I
don't know I don't know what I would do
I don't know if I would do without her
if I were her what would you guys do
what do you think be gentle be kind be
thoughtful be respectful in the comments
let me know